hoy es un nuevo día de manifestaciones a
favor de la vice presidenta cristina
fernández de kirchner aqui en argentina
hay actos en diferentes puntos del país
este es us 100 metros de su domicilio a
diferencia de lo que ha ocurrido en los
últimos seis días que han sido en la
puerta de la casa esto es aquí porque el
gobierno de la ciudad buenos aires que
es de un signo político opositor al de
la vicepresidenta decidió bajar los
accesos a su casa de hecho por ese
motivo se ha trasladado este acto aquí
que va a ser en otro lugar en un parque
de la ciudad de buenos aires es el señal
de protesta por haber puesto estos
vallados de hecho la propia
vicepresidenta salió en redes sociales a
criticar esta decisión del gobierno de
la ciudad porque se manifiestan bueno
estas manifestaciones comenzaron el
lunes por la noche luego de que la
fiscalía decidiera en el marco de la
causa llamada vialidad pedirle al
tribunal 12 años de prisión y la
inhabilitación permanente para ejercer
cargos públicos para la vicepresidenta
quienes están aquí consideran que ella
es inocente
a que esto se trata de una suerte de
persecución política es más hablan de
proscripción y muchos de estos actos a
veces parecen tener hasta un tono de
campaña electoral de hecho sobre todo
pensando en las elecciones
presidenciales del año 2023